12 est apprise est la première où en
sommes-nous de la crise sanitaire quand
et comment le monde pourra la surmonter
que faut-il faire pour éviter d'être
contaminé que faut-il faire pour être
soigné cette pandémie ne révèle pas les
fractures les lacunes de la civilisation
humaine
autant de questions que je vous propose
d'aborder aujourd'hui d'en face à la
première en ce dimanche 13 septembre
2020 c'est l'émission politique
hebdomadaire de la rédaction de
martinique la première aujourd'hui trois
invités tout d'abord à main droite se
trouve le docteur jean-luc fanon bonjour
docteur fernand bonjour monsieur partie
vous êtes gériatrie médecin gériatre ça
veut dire que vous êtes spécialisé dans
les maladies des personnes âgées ou
travailler au chu centre hospitalier
universitaire de martinique et vous êtes
membre du conseil scientifique auprès de
l' agence régionale de santé de vente
unique la rs à côté de vous le docteur
vie gene bonjour docteur et j'ai
toujours je suis partie médecin gériatre
vous également vous avez longtemps
travaillé au conseil général puis à la
septième pour travailler maintenant au
service territorial et 110 de secours le
stis chez les sapeurs-pompiers où vous
êtes colonel et puis avec nos guy albert
rouet niamey le bouchon un sourire idiot
mail bourgeon super six ingénieurs
social diplômé d'état expert en
politiques publiques sociales et vous
est également membre du conseil
scientifique de la rs alors monsieur
sans vouloir épiloguer sur les chiffres
sur les statistiques que nous publions
nous les médias en général tous les
jours pour ce qui concerne la martinique
la france l'europe le monde voire même
parfois trop rarement mais parfois la
caraïbe
les derniers chiffres donnés par le
bulletin épidémiologique hebdomadaire
publié chaque mardi par l' agence
régionale de santé donne 939 cas de
positif révélé en martinique ça fait
environ 0,24 pour cent de la population
c'est deux fois moins ce qu'en
proportion par rapport à la france mais
générale 0,53 ponsan avec plus de 340
81015 n'obtient pas non
est ce que c'est important ce genre de
mesure ce genre de statistiques de
savants combien de personnes dans une
population est contaminée par rapport à
la démographie c'est surtout par rapport
à l'évolution de l'épidémie puisque on
considère qu'une épidémie est jugulée à
partir du moment où 60 à 70 % de la
population a été contaminé ou et
vaccinés or on est loin de s'éteindre à
ça car on est très loin de ces chiffres
ce que l'on comprend c'est que la
circulation du virus est aujourd'hui
très active en martinique comme elle
l'est dont les trois territoires
d'outre-mer et sur le territoire
national ce qui distingue cette
situation de la première vague dont nous
avons souffert c'est que cette deuxième
cette deuxième vague atteint sur tous
les sujets jeunes 14 40 ans et 40 60 ans
moindre dans un moindre dans une moindre
proportion est la deuxième remarque que
que l'on est amené à faire c'est
l'absence de retentissement sur le
système de soins
notre grande inquiétude c'est le
débordement des services de soins
notamment des services de réanimation
dans la prise en charge de ces patients
elle est pas le cas aujourd'hui ce qui
n'est pas le cas et une des explications
avancées et que les personnes touchées
étant beaucoup plus jeune développant
moins de formes graves ou plus de formes
asymptomatiques
il n'y a pas de retentissement direct
sur sur les hôpitaux
par contre l'inquiétude commence à
monter notamment dans l'est dans
l'ensemble des hôpitaux en guadeloupe
mais aussi sur le territoire national
qui montrent que de plus en plus on
hospitalise des patients ce qui montre
que il ya probablement un décalage entre
le dépistage est l'apparition des formes
sévères de cette maladie en clair quand
vous êtes déclaré positif mettant lundi
vous tombez vraiment malade quatre cinq
six dix jours plus tard alors de toute
façon oui puisque on sait que d'abord on
a une
dès les premiers jours sont
asymptomatiques entre 2 et 4 4 jours
dans lesquelles vous être asymptomatique
avant que les premiers symptômes
apparaissent pendant ces 2 à 4 jours qui
précèdent les symptômes vous êtes
positif si on vous fait un test vous est
positif puis vous allez avoir une
évolution qui va durer au maximum cinq
jours puis la mezam devant disparaître
d'accord d'accord oui je me retourne
vers vous chez les sapeurs pompiers vont
également vous êtes bien placé vous êtes
une sorte d'observatoire delà des
risques sanitaires de martin gray
général est-ce que vous validez
l'observation du dock est enfin nommé
que l'on tend de plus en plus ça va
savoir que ce sont plutôt des jeunes qui
sont révélés positifs
contrairement à ce qui s'était passé
avec la première vague durant la période
de confinement ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que la première vague qu'il n'y a pas eu
autant de tests
donc on ne peut pas comparer ce qui
s'est passé la première fois et
aujourd'hui entre mars et je m'étends et
puis aujourd'hui août septembre
mais c'est sûr et certain que quand on
regarde et esquisse ont pratiqué
aujourd'hui le typhon les propos chez
des jeunes sont majoritaires et
effectivement on voit que c'est parmi
ces personnes et comme le disait ces
personnes jeunes et en septembre à
tiques sont porteuses du virus mais ne
sont pas malades
et comme vous avez aussi c'est une
personne qui peut même peuvent présenter
les signes de la maladie avec fatigue
donc on l'a eu et orissa malade et c'est
comme ça qu'on l'a su qu'ils étaient
assez jusque là déclarait dit si bien en
fait ça n'entraîne pas chez eux
les formes graves pour créer une
hospitalisation mais parce qu'il faut
faire très attention parce que plus vous
aurez des jeunes qui seront atteints
rappelez vous que ces jeunes de vie
facile et souvent ils vivent avec leurs
parents âgés
c'est la réalité et c'est ça qui est
l'objet ce que magenta les nations
rapide auprès des parents des personnes
plus âgées que les jeunes vous d'accord
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que le risque
de propagation de propagation le
personnage et qui alors sont elles-mêmes
en confinement se protège mais risque
d'être contaminé à domicile par les
enfants parce que les mesures barrières
ne sont pas forcément respectée dans un
deuxième temps c'est un risque qu'il a
pendant et donc personne ne peut prédire
l'avenir de ce soir pour en terminer
avec l'aspect statistique gilbert louis
fin du hamel est ce que la population
puisque vous êtes travaillant sociale
donc vous êtes au contact direct
notamment de publics fragiles et qu'ils
le sont encore bout encore plus du fait
de cette crise est-ce que ça a un impact
on peut dire psychologique si vous le
faites que d'avoir tous les jours à la
radio à la télévision dans les journaux
d'ici ou d'ailleurs
le nombre de personnes décédées le
nombre de cas positifs ou au contraire
s'il ya une banalisation les gens
finissent par s'habituer à ces hauts
risques comme s'il était un risque
comparable à notre ce qui concerne la
que vide pas du tout c'est bien que plus
on en parle et que les gens le prennent
au sérieux c'est qu'il ya pas du tout
mutualisation et rassurez-vous et
subarctiques boulou et ça n'est pas
qu'un société ça veut dire que cette
maladie n'est pas du tout malade est
anodine concon très très con vulgarise
parce qu'en fait on entend trop parler
qu'à la limite on en a plus besoin de
s'en faire d'ailleurs je le constate
régulièrement des dévots nos soins ce à
dire que les gens sont encore beaucoup à
quoi qu'on en dise encore confiné c'est
à dire qu'il n'a pas déconfite et tout
le monde savait à l'époque et qui par
exemple et est encore des personnes
âgées des personnes qui ont une peur
qu'ont développé aussi les attitudes
psychotiques ou émotionnelle pas pour
okobé des caisses qu'ils n'arrivent
toujours pas à sortir de chez eux et
qu'on voyait aussi le
le port du masque vous voyez
systématiquement emporté il n'y a pas
vraiment de l'esfra d'aspe réfractaires
au port du masque cas de l'auto confirme
ainsi julian pour viale l'auto
confinement il ya eu des personnes qui
sont restées un dépit des ouvertures
entre guillemets du doigt de circuler
autres c'est vrai qu'il ya à mon avis
peut être pas non plus une bonne
compréhension une bonne application la
plus orthodoxe de des mesures dites
barrière à savoir comment bien se laver
les mains comme emportés vraiment un
masque comme une pâle sourire quand vous
voyez donc figé avec son masque à
l'oreille ça vous donne une idée c'est à
dire que des gens n'ont pas forcément
les bonnes pratiques sociaux qu'on doit
travailler mais ce n'est pas du tout une
maladie banalisée aujourd'hui que la
population ça suffisamment stigmatiser
sa suffisamment de poser des problèmes
sociaux et je vous l'avais déjà dit une
fois on est vraiment dans une seconde
vague épidémique clinique mais on est
encore bien dedans dans les effets
collatéraux sociaux et autres de la
première alors je reviens sur les
statistiques le docteur enfin non
comment cela s'explique-t-il qu'on a des
situations différentes selon les
territoires
en guadeloupe à saint quentin en
martinique ou en guyane
je parle même pas de la france
continentale nous nous sommes éloignés
comme on le sait mais il y à des
situations sanitaires complètement
différente
est ce que c'est le mode de vie ce que
celles habitant qu'est ce qui explique
cette différence sans sa rentrée dans
beaucoup de taille et bien tout
simplement par la façon dont les
populations ont intégré appliquer les
gestes barrière on sait aujourd'hui que
le respect des gestes-barrières ses
terres la distanciation physique
l'hygiène le port du masque sont les
trois les trois trépied ou les trois
pieds puis les trois pieds ou les trois
règles principales qui vont nous
protéger contre le coc vide pour
l'instant on n'a pas d'autre et on n'a
toujours pas de
on n'a toujours pas de vaccin or la
manière dont c'est dans ces règles
peuvent être appliqués varient d'un
territoire à l'autre d'une population à
l'autre d'un groupe de population à
l'autre et on le voit les jeunes sont
beaucoup moins adhérents par ses
consignes au port au port du masque ou
ou à la distanciation
ils s'embrassent et le ils se côtoient
il en football il enlève le masque dès
que possible
et parce que il à cet âge là on tout le
monde le sait on est immortel donc ils
n'ont ils n'ont rien à craindre
ce qui ne mesurent pas c'est qu'il par
leur attitude ils risquent de se
contaminer et c'est ce qui est en train
de se passer et ils vont en rentrant
chez eux contaminer leurs frères et
soeurs leurs parents et qui vont
eux-mêmes contaminer leurs propres
parents or on sait que la principale
populations à risque de mortalité liée à
cette maladie ce sont les personnes
âgées pour revenir sur les données
épidémiologiques dans la caraïbe les
situations sont très contrastées
la plupart des pays autour de nous sont
très peu touchée par la coved sauf à
rivedoux dominicaine cuba rien mr haïti
on ne sait pas est-ce qu'il ya très peu
de cas signalés par rapport à la
population d'haïti près de 9 une
personne on ne sait pas c'est parce que
en raison du défaut des structures
sanitaires du défaut de l'appareil
statistique ou le fait que les haïtiens
sont non pas immunisés mais en tout cas
acquise en qui sont moins si sa pipe
d'être contaminé par la commune 19
qu'est ce que vous en dites vous
échanger avec vos confrères des pays
voisins c'est plus comique alors on a on
a évoqué
ce point qui consiste d'abord à comparer
le fait qu' il y a au mois de mars on
testait très peu et on ne testait que
les formes les plus symptomatiques voir
que les formes graves et on avait très
peu de cas aujourd'hui on teste
largement d'ailleurs peut être et
sûrement de manière abusive ont en tout
cas la stratégie des tests aujourd'hui
n'est n'est pas optimale puisque les
fils de personnes qui font la queue
devant les laboratoires pour se faire
tester en pêche peuvent empêcher les
patients réellement symptomatique ou les
personnes contacts à se faire tester
c'est ce qui est en train de remonter
aujourd'hui donc on testait peut on
avait peu de cas ou alors on est dans
des situations où on teste pas et auquel
cas on ne déclare pas de deux cas
positifs
alors donc corrigé pareil chez pour vous
chez les pompiers est-ce que vous avez
noté des changements de comportement par
rapport à ces hauts risques
tout à l'heure où chérif un duhamel
disait que effectivement la population
prend ça au sérieux ce n'est pas une
affection banalisé et je sens aller
coûte des informations appliquent les
consignes implique les conseils de leur
médecin ou de leur voisinage ou de leur
famille est ce que la population
martiniquaise a évolué dans ses
comportements par rapport à cette crise
oui c'est sûr parce que les personnes
sont compréhensifs et ils ont bien vu le
risque était pendant et donc à force de
répéter c'est d'ailleurs on dit la bonne
pédagogie c'est aussi l'heure de la
répétition et donc on observe
effectivement que les gens comprennent
et quand même les personnes qui étaient
rica le site entre ont bien compris que
les gestes barrières et notamment le
port du masque
bon vous savez qu'au début il ya eu
quelques tergiversations concernant le
port du masque et je crois que
on peut critiquer le masque on peut
l'expliquer qu'on ne peut pas bien je
crois que le corps médical en
particulier est d'ailleurs d'autres
comités métier on utilise le masque
comme mesures de protection vous devez
avoir cette barrière pour vous éviter et
de temps que vous êtes rappocher
imaginez vous un chirurgien dentiste et
qui est en train d'explorer la bouche de
quelqu'un qui n'a pas un masque alors
que la personne perspective
voilà vision en plus donc ça c'est
important
et aujourd'hui effectivement moi je
pourrais dire qu'il ya une détérioration
mais ça ne suffit pas parce qu'en
réalité il faut bien imaginer que je
peux avoir mon masque et toute la
journée
et puis au moment où il faut c'est au
moment où je ne vais pas manque de
vigilance parce que benjamin si blier je
vais rencontrer monsieur x qui lula ne
sépare ils m'interpellent ne serait ce
que pour me demander
explication je reste à parler avec lui
et on est contaminé
et puis on se dit mais au fait aussi dit
plus à brossard oui donc il est
important effectivement que d'ailleurs
dans les lieux publics on porte tout le
temps le masque possible quand on n'est
pas sûr
eh bien on se protège même question pour
gilbert williams elle farc ingénierie
sociale est ce que vous observez un
singe ou une modification de nos
comportements nous ne sommes pas
habitués dans la lah génération à
génération wii de mémoire d'homme et de
femme ou d'articles ne sommes pas
habitués à porter le masque est ce que
ça a induit des changements dans
l'attitude des gens est ce qu on a fini
par intégrer cette nouvelle norme
oui mais j'aime bien mais agir quand
même sur comment les la petit public en
tout cas la parole publique a évolué
depuis la non sur cette maladie
quelques mois déjà ou un discours où les
gens n'étaient pas du tout encourage à
porter des masques
oui effectivement il fallait peut-être
même des conseillers des jeux où
personne ne laisser la priorité aux
soignants on n'était pas du tout sûre du
stock de masques où il n'avait pas
forcément besoin on a même entendu un
ministre dira que moi même je suis pas
pour tamas on a fait des choses quand
même faut pas deviné tout à fait je veux
dire en oublie de dire et de bon sens
vous avez carrément une par le public
qui mute qui mute alors que des choses
alors je mens se dire voilà comment ça
s'est comporté quand on portait pas de
masque on a eu tant de cas on n'a pas
plus loin que ça on nous a confiné
certes mais on a en sortait sans masquer
on était simple et aujourd'hui la parole
publique a changé mais elle est devenue
une parole publique réglementaire c'est
à dire qu'elle transporte une sanction
c'est à dire que vous dites aux gens
maintenant si vous ne portez pas ce qui
aurait pu vous tuer il ya quelques mois
si vous ne portez pas non seulement vous
risquez de la décontaminer mais de
contaminer d'autres mais vous serez
sanctionné pécuniairement parlant nous
doivent une sanction pénale
mais 135 euros voilà devant la première
effraction on est aujourd'hui si vous
voulez dans alors est ce qu'aujourd'hui
les gens portent des masques
parce qu'ils ont peur de pays 135 euros
aux biens non merci la question reste
posée
ou bien est-ce qu'ils portent des
masques pas qui citait déjà convaincre
avant même que la parole publique de
mute qu'il était important de porter des
masques je dis que oui parce que
n'oubliez pas quand même des pillages
avec ses civilités on a vu des gens
portés dp2 alors qu'il l'était roubaix
comme il pouvait on a vu un commerce
parallèle on a vu des pandas n'at on a
vu toutes sortes d'artisanat naître
avant même que le port du masque soit
une parole publique qui plus est
sanctionné donc je crois que cela nous
conforte sur l'aspect jeu pas dire
pédagogique mais instinctif je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le martiniquais a
toujours été conscient que face à cette
maladie il fallait se protéger
ça c'est une question que ses papiers
pas la pédagogie qu'on nous a servi
récemment qui fait qu'on a change et et
vous verrez bien que autant il était
vrai que les personnes n'étaient pas
respectueuse des mesures de confinement
parce que les gens sortent un à un des
pieds de confinement ce conte apparu
reconnaît dans la santé disant que
généralement parlant c'est elle et le
respect qu'ils étaient respectés même
s'ils avaient des îles l'année qu'un
c'était génial que je vous dise orthez a
dit que les gens à l'eau oui alors oui
sorte à la main vite et n'était pas
comble voir avec aimé mais aujourd'hui
ça veut dire que le port du masque je
pensé que je le vois bien dans les
pratiques je le vois dans ce moment dans
les services je le voyais un monde où on
va et même dans les publics les plus
fragiles c'est à dire ceux où ses
clients supposerait que le port du
masque deviendrait un obstacle sociale
on voit qu'il est là maintenant c'est là
où je joue tiens à insister sur la
pédagogie d'ubs la bonne manière doit
porter ce masque là les gens ne savent
pas le porter il se le partagent ils
voulaient bus et c'est là où ça pose
problème
le masque du mmm ne pose pas de problème
nous y reviendrons ici à pains
déterminants culturels un facteur
culturel à noter enfin non sur le port
du masque parce qu'on a souvent dit que
dans les pays d'asie du sud
d'asie carrément la corée le japon la
chine le vietnam voire même le cambodge
les gens sont déjà habitués ils portent
le masque assez fréquemment notamment
pour se protéger de la pollution ou de
la poussière et donc ça ne me pose pas
de difficulté de ce que l'état met à
disposition depuis longtemps pour toutes
sortes de causes cette mesure de
protection ce qui est une exception dans
le monde puisque partout ailleurs nulle
part ailleurs plutôt en importe le
masque de manière systématique
est-ce que nous aussi nous n'avons pas
intégré d'autres juste alors on peut on
peut on peut noter que la population
martiniquaise a adopté très rapidement
et très facilement et de manière durable
le port du masque il ne pose quasiment
aucun problème en dehors de quelques
incidents où la population fait
elle-même la police en disant il porte
pas de masque
vous avez certes voilà vous avez déjà
observé ça c'est des gens qui font
mouche à oui ça arrive fréquemment
ah oui wind de plus en plus et le fait
que tout le monde porte le masque autour
de soi va inciter le récalcitrant à le
porter il faut savoir que et pour
convaincre le les antilles masque il il
y en a il faut savoir que une récente
publication a montré que dans les
régions où on ne respectait pas les
gestes barrières et notamment le port du
masque
le nombre de personnes qui mouraient de
l'infection du couvent du corps il était
14 fois plus important que dans les
autres régions
94 x d'amp et cette étude a été
reproduit dans plusieurs pays donc ce
qui nous incite où nous devrait nous
convaincre d'être vigilants et de
respecter les gestes barrières qu'on les
trois les trois piliers dont on parlait
tout à l'heure le port du masque
d'hygiène
l'hygiène des mains et la distanciation
physique
les trois fonctionnent en même temps il
faut pas on peut pas dire de moi je ne
ferais que le masque et je me lèverai
pas les mains où je ne je ne
respecterais pas ladite la distanciation
physique il faut absolument respecter
ces trois mesures
ce sont les seuls qui peuvent qui
peuvent nous protéger pour l'instant
distance physique ou distance sociale dr
viger est ce que vous sentez à la
population paraît ou en tout cas les
observations sais pas si je vous demande
pas votre votre sentiment mais votre
analyse objective est ce que vous
constatez que la population de
martinique s'est pliée finalement à
cette notion de distance physique qui
devient en fait la distance sociale
alors justement un peu juste parce
qu'aussi il faut pas parler de sa
situation sociale
on peut avoir un masque et garder de
bonnes relations sociales et je crois
que ce mot il a fallu le corrigé assez
rapidement parce que en fait la
traduction que celui qui l'écrit la
première fois elle était mal on va dire
mal interprété j'aurai deux fois ci
c'est sur la notion de distanciation
physique donc avec la mesure du masque
qui sépare physiquement mais on se veut
pas dire que l'on n'est pas proche
socialement les gens à réaliser au
quotidien effectivement jean luc roy
nous l'a dit je crois que la population
martiniquaise
la du bon sens l'a dit mon sens il ya
peut-être fallu assister au début qui
comprennent et qu'ils voient le risque
qui pendant ou bien comprendre que
effectivement l'une des mieux quitter la
simple et facile à mettre en place
c'était le masque
donc oui la population je crois que la
guerre et la dire de plus en plus à
l'est dans les pays occidentaux les pays
où il ya le port du masque est il et il
est plus facilement utilisé parce qu'ils
ont eu l'habitude est quand vous allez
en chine ou en russie pays d'asie ou
d'asie du sud-ouest mais l'asie en
général et plus particulièrement la
chine que je connais le port du masque
sait plus où fait depuis des années et
donc ce pas surprenant que une défection
qui scella et dans le disait qu'il
fallait pour savoir que c'est un réflexe
facile et qui voit alors ici on évoque
énormément d'éléments pour que la
chaleur ceci moi je vais vous dire il
faut il faut toutes ces considérations
pour prendre un exemple des sapeurs
pompiers sur les feux un moi-même qui va
comme eux mais à quatorze après midi
samedi après midi dans le sud
dot et déjà fait debout ça et vous
imaginez la température qui fait
effectivement si le masque est mouillé
je vais le changer parce que les
mouiller on peut difficilement le
remplace mais le port du masque
n'empêche pas
le travail est d'ailleurs les histoires
bailleurs qui ont le même les fstd parce
que je suis les chantiers se sont dits
ffp2 qui quand je vous dis y'a aucune
difficulté donc je crois comme c'est la
coutume c'est une question d'habitude
et aussi de dessiccation du bénéfice et
du bénéfice par rapport au juste que
vous allez faire si vous aimez ce n'est
pas nécessaire si vous estimez créé
inhalé de la poussière par exemple avec
son masque ça ne vous gêne pas avec les
quelques années après vous vous plaignez
êtes malade dont il faut avoir aussi du
bon sens juste une petite parenthèse
historique lors de l'éruption volcanique
de l'appel de 1929 y avait des sceaux
nombre de parents tous très loin jusqu'à
fort-de-france et la population avaient
des masques en tout cas qu'elle
confectionnait elle même avec des
morceaux de tissus et pendant des
semaines et des semaines on a oublié où
on ne sait pas puisque ce sont d
ailleurs nos grands-parents 1929 sais
pas je dis c'est une simple parenthèse
guy albert rifains duhamel là le conseil
scientifique nationale vient de déclarer
que la 14ème scène autres sujets que
j'aborde évidemment la mise en
quarantaine pendant 14 jours 14 n est
inefficace parce que le nul aucune
autorité ne peut contrôler les personnes
soumises à ce régime l'appliquent
réellement et donc à les rabaisser à
sept jours est-ce que ça on crut pas ça
ne risque pas détruit encore de la
confusion de la parole publique que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure oui parce qu'en
fait c'est freddy coni dans la jeu est
bien vu que je parle pas de politique je
parle seulement de parole c'est
l'expression publique qui est une
expression qui est très fluctuante c'est
à dire qu'on a eu on a du mal à trouver
une tonalité à cette parole est
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que nous avons
sans parler de certaines donc on
on avait déjà évoqué sa manière même
avant que le national arrive à cela le
conseil scientifique de martinique avait
déjà évoqué cette hypothèse
et puis aussi la légalité de ces mesures
la cité de liberté ne m'étais pas
impunément déjà comme ça il ya quand
même un contrôle de ces choses là et
puis on peut pas non plus un maître jean
d'andean tout le monde et puis quand
même il ya gendarmes ce n'est pas un
excès pas une incarcération donc c'est
pas aussi simple je crois qu'aujourd'hui
ce que ça vous fait quoi on va c'est à
dire c'est ce respect de la soul et de
davantage de la distanciation physique
des gestes barrières amplifié et de
l'évitement du collectif et j'aurais
préféré d'abord semoule à que parler
vraiment ciblé de 14 m de certaines
comme si nous étions dans un dôme
étaient des gens dans un aquarium
quelque part à pas et quand les enlever
de la société ce qui n'est manifestement
pas possible et nous avons une somme à
distance de ces mesures de confinement
mais aussi ses mesures de 14 m et nous
documentons à peine les premières et à
clé première chose qu'il remonte du vécu
de ces 14 n essaie d'ailleurs qui a
porté cette nouvelle parole publique qui
montrait que déjà sur le plan clinique
et pas forcément de valeur ajoutée plus
que ça qu'on compte en tête on étudie en
tout cas la période dite d'être une
nation et de développement de symptômes
mais aussi sur le plan social les effets
totalement délétère qu'on a observés
chez les gens qui est en 14ème poumon
tue tout est un exemple on a eu des
personnes qui étaient en 14ème dans des
hôtels qui générèrent famille qui se
retrouver à pour les enterrements de
on termine est venue enterrer son papa
qu'il a été muet dans une quatorzaine
peut-elle a connu la coque pas moi si
vous et qui me disait mais coûte c'est
carrément unis c'est à dire que je nous
sommes dans une quatorzaine on a mangé
une gamme n on peut sentir pratiquement
quand on veut sauf ramené à à manger en
avions nous ont dit qu'à mais ça qu'ils
passent un nouveau mais en réalité c'est
à dire on était incapable si vous voulez
de régler vraiment les mesures de
gestion de la 14ème et il a quand même
pu sortir parce qu'il fallait qu'il
aille à l'enterrement qui lie à la
veillée et peu ou aucune aucune mesure
de contrôle c'est-à-dire la 14è n'était
une sorte placebo c'est à dire ça le
fait de dire qu'il était placé en 14ème
le rendait non non non contagieux donc
je crois vraiment qu'on n'a pas
forcément su bien bien bien agir ici
14/n passé à septèmes pourquoi pas mais
ce serait en tout cas ce qui me concerne
davantage soudé mesure mieux encadré
de distanciation physique les instrus
critique ce qu'il faudrait faire ce
qu'on fait déjà ça veut dire le respect
des notions derrière ça vaut la peine de
faire en avant d'en faire davantage
d'après vous donc enfin non vous n'êtes
pas d'accord alors je vais rajouter je
me permettrai pas de pas être d'accord
avec gilbert hulin prouver je voudrais
simplement rajouté que la raison pour
laquelle le conseil scientifique a pris
cet avis est liée à la meilleure
connaissance que nous avons maintenant
de la contagiosité de ceux de ce virus
en fait on sait qu'aujourd'hui que un
patient infecté est contagieux
deux jours avant que les premiers
symptômes apparaissent quand là quand la
maladie est symptomatique et il reste
contagieux pendant cinq jours donc on
est à sept jours et donc poursuivre au
delà l'isolément n'avait plus aucun sens
la deuxième raison c'est que celle
qu'avancent galbées rufin c'est qu'en
réalité bain au bout de sept jours
souvent les gens ne supportaient plus
c'est un petit peu l'histoire qu'on a
eues avec les antibiotiques ont prescrit
veille dix jours d'antibiotiques et au
bout de cinq jours vous n'avez plus de
symptômes vous arrive vous arrêtiez le
traitement est on on sait aujourd'hui
que les traitements courbin soit aussi
efficace que les traitements longs donc
je pense que c'est plus une meilleure
connaissance de deux scientifiques de
cette maladie qui qui explique cette
position ce qui nous amène d'ailleurs à
penser que le moment on doit faire le
test doit aussi nous interroger puisque
on sait que par exemple le test
qu'ovide le testerine au prélèvement
rhinopharyngé est bien née positif que
que pendant les pour les mêmes raisons
que deux jours avant que les symptômes
apparaissent et il devient négatif cinq
jours après donc si vous faites le test
trop tard et bien vous serez négatif
d'autre part si vous au moment où vous
devenez symptomatique vous n'êtes pas
sujets contacts vous devenez
symptomatique et vous cherchez à faire
un test
si vous devez attendre trois jours avant
qu'un laboratoire vous reçoivent vous
risquez et que et qu'après il vous faut
trois jours pour avoir le résultat est
bien un moment vous avez le résultat
vous n'êtes plus contagieux mais vous
avez déjà contaminé tout le monde donc
en fait si vous êtes symptomatique
faites vous dépister
mais isolé vous tout de suite isolé vous
tout de suite en prévision du résultat
c'est un peu compliqué nous sommes nous
sommes d'accord à vivre pour quelqu'un
qui est peut se sentir fébrile avec
quelques signes parce qu'on sait que
mots sur les maux de tête c'est une
fatigue extrême
c'est une fièvre c'est un problème ce
sont des courbatures et c'est finalement
la dengue qui va être reprise et avec
l'arrivée de la grippe
oui la grippe va là on va rentrer dans
une période où on va avoir une épidémie
de grippe qui va se développer en même
temps que l'épidémie ducobu en même
temps que nos propres infection locale
et notamment la dengue même si c'est un
automatisme en latin qu'on fait
cliniquement on arrive plus facilement à
faire la différence mais mais pas du
tout avec la grippe ce sera exactement
la même chose et avec les mêmes
conséquences parce que contrairement à
ce qu'on pense la grippe n'est pas une
maladie
si anodine que ça en particulier pour
nos populations âgées et elle a encore
tué treize mille personnes 1 dernière en
france donc ce n'est pas une c'est pas
une maladie anodine
justement de corriger sur cette question
compliquée du test vous il ya pas
vraiment de solution parce que là on
sait qu'il ya de plus en plus de gens
qui seront testés ça devient compliqué
pour les laboratoires publics au chu ou
privés
en ville de se faire tester les files
d'attentes sont longues les résultats ne
parviennent pas avant deux jours parfois
trois dans les cas extrêmes bon mais
finalement est-ce qu'il faut faire
tester
même si on ne se sent pas malade ou pas
d'après vous je vais aller plus à
contre-courant en réalité on a une
problématique de responsabilisation des
individus soit quand vous parlez de 14 m
si vous voulez donner quelques uns ont
soif à dire que mais ça c'est plus que
dans les départements métropolitains
vous avez malheureusement des personnes
qui vivent sur 12 de calais où ils sont
24 là effectivement sortir ces personnes
sur 10 mais non pas les isoler et d
empêcher les infecter d'autres il faut
bien comprendre la différence
j'ai des conditions de vie correcte non
mes parents ont une vie lara exemple
j'ai ma chambre je vais effectivement on
se dit même isolé mais pour le pape ont
terminé mais on oublie l'utilisation du
masque j'ai une suspicion gel contaminés
je suis fier heureux j'ai des signes qui
pourrait ressembler à ceux du coup vide
mais qui peuvent ressembler aussi ceux
de la grippe ou encore simplement
rassemblement français donc je vais
faire le pinguiss un masque devant le
laboratoire
en attendant comme diagnostic est énorme
mettez votre masque pour protéger
d'abord et ensuite oui un petit peu
grâce à des méthodes
c'est le premier cas ce sont des gens
qui se sentent
malin de fiévreux février le disant mais
si on a sans aucun signe mais qu'il est
de bon ton d'aller se faire tester tout
de même nom mais justement mais le
problème c'est le problème c'est que
comme com comment devant une situation
qui ne s'apparente pas forcément quoi la
panique mais qui est la peur des
individus parce que j'ai peur
on me dit que je peux être contaminés on
me dit ça j'entends ça toute la journée
on me dit fais tout tester mais il ya
plein de gens comme ça dans des files
d'attentes devant les avons informés et
ils nourrissent pas question de passer
devant eux
alors je suis malade et que je tousse
c'est pas le problème et ils veulent
vérifier pour eux-mêmes
donc comment faire une police de sa c6
tout autre le message le sens civique
qui doit voir c'est exactement vous avez
raison et le sens civique le bon sens et
je crois que ça l'est quand un message
de santé publique
il est pollué et il est mal parti après
c'est compliqué de le rattraper rectifié
voyez ce qu'il veut et donc moi je dis
que aujourd'hui il s'agit pas de dire à
nos gouvernants de fin mai inculpables
jeudi ont écouté un moment donné on n'a
pas eu les moyens
rim est maintenant de manière unanime
nous sommes tous d'accord qu'il faut
porter le masque au moindre signe au
moins deux malaises vous porter le
masque on vous donne la possibilité de
rester chez vous d'ailleurs dans les
mesures gouvernementales on vous dit que
vous vouliez vous avez fait héééé
jean-luc je te dirais bien que
aujourd'hui on a le problème des enfants
ce week-end dire enfin le week-end passé
plus tôt
on a l'exemple d'un professionnel qui
dit voilà j'ai mon enfant qui a atteint
fief je suis un professionnel
qu'est ce que je fais la réponse que je
lui fais je suis écouté je ne peux pas
vous dire si c'est la dengue fièvre vous
isolez votre enfant vous voyez votre
médecin traitant
mais vous en tant que professionnel vous
même aussi vous devez pas les mesures
barrières avec masque et tout dit à
votre employeur que le sens de faire les
analyses et bien vous allez payer ce
qu'on va y est
et donc là vous faites la preuve de
civisme donc c'est cette éducation qu'il
faut arriver pour un petit peu faire on
va dire presque du cas par cas
alors peut-être que si il faut des
moyens un personnel à l'ecoute pouvoir
répondre à des questionnements qui sont
là et puis mais il faut mettre un
système qui permet mais c'est possible
il ya de multiples cas en guadeloupe
lundi amelia parce qu'il ya plusieurs il
ya plusieurs situations individuelles
qui font que un moment donné mais
autorités ont peut-être du mal à suivre
ce que la population attend d'elle ou à
l'inversé les autorités ont du mal à se
faire comprendre une population qui vit
ses hauts risques de manière différente
y en a qui ont très peur il y en a qui
sont est différent il y en a qui font
semblant de vergers de ne pas être
concernées c'est extrêmement divers
comme aurillac c'est un des individus
ce que nous on est unanime si que tout
mon temps que ça s'arrête là c'est une
que ce soit au niveau des individus les
plus réfractaires peu importe son niveau
des services publics ce qu'on veut c'est
que cette épidémie ce qu'on tienne il
compte que ça s'arrête un moment je
pense que ça commence à un peu fatigué
mais hélas ce que disait font bondir un
peu sur mon collègue d'un objet c'est à
dire que on est dans une posture où il
faut savoir ce qu'on dit les mesures
barrières ça a été rappelé par jean-luc
fanon c'est à dire que le lavage des
mains c'est à dire avec que des
solutions d'une colique mais aussi de
l'eau et du savon
le port du masque et puis respect d'une
distanciation physique cela est possible
- m si nous disons ça à la population
nous lui disons qu en réalité nous lui
disons qu'en respectant sa elle protège
les autres et elle se protège
il faudra ajouter un quatrième élément
donc dans ces cas là qu'on me dise c'est
à dire ce qui a besoin de distanciation
physique plus corsée c'est-à-dire à
savoir qu'il faudrait peut-être de décès
p'tain des 14 et nos gens passent
faudrait que ça c'est ce qu'on dit est
ce qu'une personne dans un avion qui
potentiellement infectées par la crise
enfin pas parce oui cela est dans
l'avion avec son masque qui se lave les
mains qui respecte et cetera est-ce
qu'il va contaminer quelqu'un dans
l'avion oui ou non s'il contamine pas
dans l'avion pourquoi contamine les
télés au sol donc je crois qu'à un
moment et c'est là où je porte si vous
voulez important de messages publics
claire et plus on va rajouter deux
choses à des choses déjà très difficile
et très et à comprendre et à digérer
surtout quand on a eu une entrée en
épidémie relativement cacophonique
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui ce risque est
à dire tantôt 14 santos est bientôt
d'après rien à un moment il faut garder
ce discours là donc je suis partisan en
tout cas ce qui concerne pas en tant
qu'ingénieur je ne me permettrais pas de
m'exprimer sur le plan clinique
si nous sommes d'accord que les besoins
barria comporte 3 c est à dire savoir le
port systématique de masque dès lors
qu'on à contacter la boîte aux lettres
d'une personne le lavage des mains le
plus rapidement le peuple le plus
souvent possible avec une solution hydro
alcoolique ou encore de l'eau et du
savon d'andenne entendu en respectant un
délai suffisant pour ne pas passer pas
juste de rinçage des masses et le lavage
des mains et en respectant une
dénonciation physique je veux dire de
proximité sociale est tout à fait
différent au contraire il faut renforcer
les liens sociaux
on peut aujourd'hui prévenir le fait
d'avoir être contaminés mais où ce qu'on
va éviter aussi de contaminer les autres
et seul apple à mon avis sauf avis
contraire du médecin largement suffire
si ça n'est pas le gars qu'on le dise
franchement dr jim sheridan en pratique
il s'exprime tout est en train de penser
à quelque chose pour donner l'exemple
des sapeurs pompiers
nous avons des mesures de protection que
nous avons appliqué et donc le port du
masque commencé depuis un mois de mars
lorsque nous avions et des masques en
stock
donc on a plus utilisé ndao misé
protocole pour les sapeurs-pompiers et
qui ont montré leur efficacité parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons aucun
sapeurs pompiers martiniquais qui a été
contaminé jusqu'au jour où les choses
soient claires il ya des
sapeurs-pompiers qui envient locaux
vides mais à l'extérieur ils sont partis
en voyage il était avec ses rimes et
contaminé au niveau professionnel ça
n'existe pas et ça confirme un petit peu
ce que je vous disais je savais jamais
de situation on l'appelle pour un risque
koffi d'américains qui a dessiné truc on
peut penser que c'est ça on demande aux
sapeurs pompiers de s'équiper avec des
tenues risques biologiques afin de
confondre avec les lunettes parce qu'il
peut avoir des projections au niveau des
yeux avec le masque ffp2 ces gars là
parce qu'il ya un risque d'y avoir des
actes invasifs
donc c'est une projection les gants il
est habillé au maximum et au coeur la c1
par à broyer et la situation des sapeurs
pompiers qui a une mesure de protection
moindre donc il n'a pas ce rappel le
pays mais il a sa veste fermée
havas qui a séduit ses gants son masque
chirurgical parfois et il était au vient
chez monsieur bart qui sait si michel
parenty a t on pas ces partis ne le sait
même pas lui-même
absolument
on reçoit une information ultérieure en
disant que cette victime met la tête
mais le pompier qui était allé n'avait
pas la veste le poulet le ou les copies
sont rattachés ok qu'est ce qu'on fait à
ce moment-là nous applique loi en photo
que nous avons mis en place de
surveillance médicale renforcée et cette
science médicale c'est que le médecin
sapeur pompier on va donc c'est un homme
simple et aux pompiers qui va appeler
régulièrement pouvait s'assurer que il a
le port le son masque au travail parce
que le port du masque est obligatoire à
cazères si on doit une suspicion qui
l'oreille est en contact on lui
demandera de mettre la protection à son
domicile sis de suite
voyant un petit peu donc mais mais mais
on ne va pas systématiquement l'envoyons
la boîte wafir des analyses le 1014
ainsi à ce moment là on aurait plus de
sapeurs-pompiers donc en tout cas il est
suivi voilà mais il est suivi et lorsque
ce protocole donc il faudrait arriver à
mettre en place pour qu'il peut être un
peu compliqué la population générale et
je pense qu'il faut suivre cette
tendance le milieu professionnel et aux
fusions arriver à surmonter la peur
alors justement condamnée au galbe et
enfin djamel disait il tout le monde
martinique mais je vais dire tout même
si la planète on a assez en main et ça
me permet de
d'aborder la dernière ligne droite de
l'émission l'organisation mondiale de la
santé oms dit espérer que la pandémie
sera jugulée dans moins de deux ans à
lyon en gros 18 mois puisqu'elle a
commencé il ya environ huit buts 10 mois
est-ce que vos médecins vous y croyez
vous qu en terme de religion de croyance
mais est-ce que vous êtes optimiste
quant au fait de pouvoir juguler cette
pandémie
leurs fans c'est une donnée de santé
publique c'est le les épidémies évolue
toujours de la même manière et c'est
simplement sur cette affirmation et
cette reconnaissance des épidémies
précédentes qu'on peut affirmer que
l'épidémie va forcément décroître je
vais revenir sur un point c'est que la
distanciation physique on va toutes les
mesures barrières non pas seulement pour
objet d'éviter de contaminer son voisin
mais c'est d'éviter qu'ils meurent si
vous pas oublier que c'est une maladie
qui fait mourir sur les chiffres de
l'étude dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure où on comparait les pays qui
avaient appliqué de manière rigoureuse
les trois mesures distanciation physique
port du masque et gign avec la
différence du nombre de morts est
considérable c'est plus 8000 morts dans
les pays qui ont appliqué les règles
barrière plus 87 mille morts dans les
pays qui n'appliquent pas donc ce n'est
pas simplement éviter d'avoir la grippe
c'est éviter de mourir soi même ou de
tuer son voisin où sa grand mère alors
justement sur la fin de la pandémie vous
dites que toutes les épidémies
fonctionne la même façon donc il faut
clients un nombre suffisamment important
de personnes malades pour que l'épidémie
c'est vrai que c'est ça mais il faut pas
que tout le monde tombe malade en même
temps à ruyver sais ce que c'est ce qui
s'est passé qui peut contrôler ça très
bien
les mesures barrières qui le contrôle
c'est ce qui s'est passé en angleterre
ce qui s'est passé aux états unis où on
adiba on va on va faire de la
contamination forcée et quand tout le
monde aura attrapé et bien plus personne
n'aura le coc vide
oui sauf que brésil aussi c'est ce qui
se passait au brésil oui sauf que quand
on a regardé les courbes de mortalité et
qu'on a dit au président 3 1 que si on
continue comme ça c'est 300 mille morts
aux etats unis
il a mis le holà donc les les gestes
barrières on le sait empêche surtout
l'afflux de patients graves en même
temps dans les établissements et
aujourd'hui ce que l'on observe et la
crainte que font remonter aujourd'hui
les équipes hospitalières dont la
guadeloupe c'est attention là on va être
on va être débordée
donc oui j'ai même question vous pensez
que nous pouvons raisonnablement au
finir avec cette épidémie d'ici un an et
demi environ
c'est à dire me 2022 en gros le virus ne
va pas disparaître et en réaliser
effectivement le nombre de personnes à
tête va se réduire parce que hein comme
j'en ai trop vielle de dire les gens
insectivores on se protège et donc si
moi je veux pas que ça m'arrive je
prends mes précautions
mais lorsque les mains et pourtant
effectivement plus on a déjà contaminé -
soit le porteur et pour dire les choses
autrement
j'ai été contaminé
donc je suis autour du maire alors avec
la guille mais à un moment donné j'ai
des anticorps qui me permet de me
défendre et donc si j'étais contaminées
dans l'est on va dire dans les 24 48
heures je ne serai pas qu'on termine en
pour les autres entre guillemets
donc si j'en rencontre mais chez ruffet
je ne serai pas importants vont lui
c'est sahara l'idée que plus de gens
soient elles étaient contaminés pour le
pas en fait sur les mini c est pour dire
simplement donc ce discours cela dit
vous qu'on connaît dans toutes les
épidémies
d'ailleurs au sénat la dengue vous avez
vu de la démo ne reste pas au stade
épidémique tout tu tenais à vous voulez
ça c'était la même manière effectivement
alors après à quelle distance du
combattant mais n'attend pas mais alors
mais qui mais on ne connaît pas encore
très bien ce que souhaitent qu vie de 19
c il existe depuis le nouveau dessin
mais le creux victime ne fore on le
connaît spécifiquement mais c'est de la
catégorie des heures son label les
coronavirus et des gels de la grippe a
et qu'on a vu son nikon est alors oui le
sport spécifique qui pose problème parce
qu'on n'a pas une bonne connaissance
mardi manière générale on connaît le
fonctionnement des virus et des
épidémies
quand vous êtes voilà assez vous êtes
plutôt optimiste mois on devrait avoir
juguler l'épidémie planétaire de déjà
séance comme deux déjà en termes de
traitement
oui on a fait un bond extraordinaire
extraordinaire on a bien vu que certains
gestes que l'on faisait n'était pas
forcément pro pauvres la trouvait
d'ailleurs dé certains médicaments qui
ont des effets notamment sur les formes
graves notamment cette satire kma3 donc
qu'on le veuille ou non on va arriver
moi le seul truc que je déplore c'est
que on met sur la place publique se
méfier des podiums des spécialistes qui
ont besoin de calme de sérénité et
surtout pas de supporter médiatique pour
vous re travailler oui alors le soir il
faut qu'ils aillent à la télévision il
faut qu'il dise quelque chose c'est le
journaliste qui fait son boulot eddy
médy tous quelque chose
mais qu'est ce que j'avais trouvé ici
mais je vois je vois et divers donc la
vue non c'est pourquoi nous invitons ici
des médecins que très rarement un
laboratoire
astrazeneca pour ne pas le nommer austro
britanniques australiens
anglo-australien a habité il pratique
elle qu'un jour la phase 3 de
l'expérimentation de vaccins que le mmm
est considéré comme le plus prometteur
le plus abouti parce que impatients on
ne sait pas où exactement a contracté
une maladie inconnue est inattendue
alors je rappelle qu'il ya plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
sont en train de tester ce vaccin au
brésil en chine et une pause états unis
c'est un coup d'arrêt c'est une pose
comment vous interpréter ça d'abord le
laboratoire astrazeneca applique le
principe de précaution
il n'est pas le seul à développer des
vaccins il ya plusieurs candidats
vaccins actuellement développé par
plusieurs laboratoires et c'est
d'ailleurs plutôt saturé été saluée
comme étant un aspect positif et on ne
doute pas comme pour le vaccin de la
grippe ou pour d'autres vaccins que
d'ici quelques mois alors dans quel
délai
on ne sait pas on aura un ou plusieurs
facs en notre disposition
le mot de la fin est également pour le
docteur obligés vous êtes vous pensez
que là on va arriver assez rapidement à
des formes le vaccin qui pourront guérir
en tout cas une partie de l'humanité
puisque nous ne sommes pas seulement
après selon quels délais est-ce qu'on va
se retrouver comme vaccin du type vaccin
antigrippal qu'il faudra renouveler
chaque année ça c'est un autre problème
mais il y aura des solutions on y voit
des solutions de prévention on va dire
et on a des solutions effectivement des
guérisons pour permettre à des personnes
qui vont nous avons des personnages et
d'être sauvé il n'avait pas mourir comme
ça le connaît
et pour terminer gayle berry fin du
hamel même pardon nous avons déjà
traversé plusieurs catastrophes dans
l'histoire
notre pays est ce que nous n'avons pas
ne pas développer une forme de
résistance de résilience cette fois ci
encore pour affronter si on monte et
oublié je puis dire centre et la
résidence on a déjà donc je pense qu'on
a déjà développé je crois c'est bon
espoir que d'ici les prochains mois
voire peut-être deux prochaines années
on va en sortir sur le plan médical mais
je pense qu'on aura plusieurs décennies
pour s'en sortir sous les vraies
conséquences sociales et je pense que
sans vraie mutation des politiques
publiques parce qu'on doit tirer quand
même des enseignements 20 on ne peut pas
non plus sortir de cela uniquement par
un vaccin
ça va quand même demandé une politique
de prévention politique également
d'accompagnement d'anticipation sur tout
et puis une politique qui va consacrer
si vous voulez c'est un nombre de
mesures et je crois que tout ce qu'ils
savent tout ce qui s'est déjà passé et
tout ce qui va se passer encore on voit
de nouvelles articulations avec les met
à l'essai sériès les pompiers et il est
fort à parier que d'ici les prochaines
des prochains mois qu'on aura un nouveau
socle législatif et réglementaire qui
intégra en tout cas cet espace nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler avec
heures ou même monsieur gilbert où il
fait du hamel ingénieurs social nokia
obligés colin meads et colonel chez les
sapeurs-pompiers et mais un docteur
fanon gériatre au chu de martinique
c'est ainsi que se conclut notre
émission face à la première réalisée
aujourd'hui par adel de doux et patrice
à la guise alacchi vous pourrez la
retrouver sur notre site internet
martinique la première point fr dans
quelques instants le journal de la mi
journée
je vous confie volontiers à michel
thimon rendez vous dimanche prochain
pour une nouvelle émission force
et puis courage bannu tout moment à plus
tard